[Musique]
Messieurs, bonjour. Nous vous recevons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne YouTube qui
s'appelle Syerview. On aurait aimé un
petit peu avoir votre vision sur les
marchés financiers, sur la politique de
certains États en terme de questions
monétaire, d'évasion fiscale et de
petite joyeuseté. Nous avons aujourd'hui
Philippe Béchad et Jérôme Cazz. Philippe
Béchad, présentez-vous, je vous
écoute. Je suis euh à l'origine un un
trader sur les marchés dérivés et puis
euh j'ai bifurqué au début des années 90
vers l'information financière. J'ai créé
Cercle Finance. Depuis 2000, je
collabore avec les éditions Agora et je
suis actuellement rédacteur en chef à la
bourse au quotidien. Je m'occupe
justement de tous les contenus traitant
de la
macroéconomie et puis accessoirement, je
suis président des éconoclastes. Jérôme
Cazz, euh je ne suis pas du tout un
financier, j'ai longtemps été un
assureur. J'ai dirigé le groupe COFAS et
à ce titre, j'ai participé au comité de
direction générale d'une grande banque
qui commence par NA et qui finit par
XIS. Et j'ai été tellement effaré par la
finance de marché que j'ai décidé de
consacrer une partie de mon énergie à
dénoncer cette espèce de malheur qui
nous est arrivé depuis une vingtaine
d'années. J'aiécris un thriller que on
peut trouver gratuitement sur internet
qui s'appelle 555 jeudi
rouge et j'essaie de d'alerter sur les
défaillances graves et et continues de
la réglementation financière.
Accessoirement, j'ai fait une start-up
pour euh faciliter euh les
communications euh entre les petites
entreprises et tous leurs partenaire qui
s'appelle euh My Cercle. On va rester
sur vous Jérôme Cazz. Euh vous essayez
d'alerter sur euh le système financier.
Quels sont les dangers qui peuvent se
matérialiser devant nous à court, moyen
et long terme ?
À mon sens, les dangers sont les mêmes
qu'il y a 8 ans. C'est-à-dire que euh on
a une finance de marché qui s'est
développée de manière absolument
invraisemblable, en volume, en
importance dans l'ensemble des
mécanismes euh économiques. Euh elle
était très importante il y a 8 ans, elle
est tout aussi importante aujourd'hui.
Pas plus importante si si on prend un
certain nombre de paramètres de volume,
elle est plus importante aujourd'hui et
plus important encore que le volume. Un
des problèmes à mon sens que nous avons
aujourd'hui, c'est celui de la taille
des plus gros animaux. Comparaison que
je fais toujours, c'est de dire les les
petits animaux font des petites bêtises,
les gros animaux font des grosses
bêtises. Et donc une des manières dans
un univers où on sait pas grand-chose et
où bah oui, on peut pas toujours
invoquer le principe de précaution. Donc
de temps en temps, il faut prendre des
risques. Une des manières d'éviter les
risques atroces, c'est d'avoir des
entités, des organisations qui soient
pas trop grande pour qu'elle fassent pas
de trop grosses bêtises. Et donc, on
avait de trop grosses banques en 2008 et
les grosses banques sont devenues encore
plus grosses aujourd'hui. Et on est
toujours dans un syndrome des gens qui
sont censés contrôler les banques, qui
pour leur confort intellectuel plus que
pour la paix de la planète sont toujours
dans l'idée que les gros, c'est quand
même sympathique parce que ce qu'on on
sait ce qu'on fait avec eux, ils savent
nous prendre dans le sens du poil nous
régulateur et donc on aime bien. Les
petits c'est compliqué, ça peut se
casser la figure. Et je pense qu'il faut
qu'on arrive à se dire que dans une
économie, il est normal qu'il y ait des
choses qui se cassent la figure. Mais
des petites choses qui se cassent la
figure, ça fait pas les titres des
journaux et ça fait de mal à personne.
Des grosses choses qui se cassent la
figure, ça fait ce qu'on a vu en 2008.
Philippe Béchad, quelles sont les
grosses choses qui vont se casser qui
vont se casser la figure selon vous à
court, moyen et long terme ? Je ne peux
pas parce que je n'ai pas de boule de
cristal à
annoncer et vous dresser le scénario.
Euh je peux vous parler des
potentialités de big problème. Euh on
parlait des gros animaux qui font des
grosses bêtises. Je pense que celui qui
aujourd'hui nous met dans la situation
la plus explosive c'est la
Chine. La Chine en 2000 c'est 1500
milliards de PIB. Euh aujourd'hui, c'est
10300 milliards de PIB.
Euh la
Chine en
20056 c'était 3000 milliards de dettes.
Aujourd'hui, c'est un peu plus de 33
milliards. C'est les dernières données
dont on dispose. Donc on voit que la
dette chinoise, celle de l'État, des
régions, des entreprises qui sont des
conglomérats le plus souvent
étatiques. La globalité de cette dette
qui est directement gérée par le
gouvernement chinois aujourd'hui donc
c'est 10 fois la taille du PIB
chinois. La Chine aujourd'hui
représente à peu près 15 % du commerce
mondial. Mais sur les 200000 milliards
de dettes aujourd'hui la Chine en
représente également plus de plus de 15
%. Les États-Unis revendiquent ou à vous
euh 18000 milliards de dettes, 100 103 %
du
PIB. La Chine, c'est 300 % du PIB, ce
qui est à peu près comparable au Japon.
Or, on se souvient qu'au Japon, dans les
années 90, on avait également connu une
explosion de la dette, des mauvaises
dettes, du du surinvestissement partout,
de la bulle immobilière. On a absolument
tous ces ingrédients en Chine mais à une
échelle qui est euh qui est quatre ou
cinq fois celle que le Japon présenter
en 1990. Jérôme, euh on fait comment
pour réguler tout ça ? Mais le je suis
tout à fait d'accord. Le le en gros
quand est-ce qu'il y a une crise ? Il y
a une crise, il faut que ce soit gros.
Bon, on l'a dit, il faut qu'il y ait des
anticipations positives. On commence à
avoir aujourd'hui des bruits négatifs
sur la Chine, mais enfin malgré tout,
les débats, c'est pour dire est-ce
qu'ils vont faire 8 ? Est-ce qu'ils vont
faire 7 ? vous n'y connaissez rien, ils
vont faire 6 et demi. Enfin, ça reste
des anticipations extrêmement positives.
Personne n'a vraiment de scénario
catastrophe. Mais mais c'est des
anticipations avec des lunettes roses ou
c'est des
anticipations sourcées, fondées ? Ah ben
peu de monde sait exactement comment se
fabriquent les statistiques chinoises et
et à vrai dire aujourd'hui la Chine
reste un fantasme mais avant c'était
aussi un fantasm n'avait pas vraiment
d'importance pour l'économie mondiale.
Aujourd'hui c'est a une vraie importance
pour l'économie mondiale. Donc ils sont
gros. Les anticipations restent
globalement positives et leur expertise
leur moi je suis un assureur donc je
pense que en gros le futur ressemble
quand même un tout petit peu au passé.
C'est pas des gens très malins les
assureurs mais il regardent le passé.
Donc en gros, une organisation, elle est
d'autant plus aguérie qu'elle a
l'habitude de résoudre des problèmes. On
peut pas dire que le management chinois
soit très habitué à régler des problèmes
de crise financière grave. Ou alors ce
qu'on peut dire, c'est que toute leur
tradition c'est de le régler de manière
brutale. Et donc c'est vrai que j'ai pas
du tout moi non plus de boule de
cristal. Donc ça peut tout à fait surgir
à un autre endroit, mais on voit bien
que en Chine, il y a les principaux
ingrédients pour qu'il y ait des choses
qui surprennent de manière négative et
que du coup tout le monde se replie sur
soi et qu'on ait bah une crise comme on
en a tous les tous les 8 ou 10 ans.
L'Europe, le scénario est comment pour
l'Europe ? l'Europe. Moi, j'ai j'ai
toujours été positif sur l'Europe,
c'est-à-dire que j'observe que on
narrête pas de se faire des petites
peurs sur l'Europe, mais ça reste des
petites
peurs. En gros, pour qu'il y ait crise,
il faut quand même qu'il y ait déjà eu
des anticipations et de la croissance.
Dans un univers à 1 % de
croissance, avec des anticipations qui
sont aussi à 1 %, il est très difficile
de bâtir un scénario de catastrophe. Euh
donc pour moi euh l'Europe a de graves
problèmes euh de gouvernance, de graves
problèmes liés au flux démographique.
Oui, il y a des problèmes, mais c'est
pas ça qui va mettre euh la toute la
planète en crise à mon sens. Philippe
Béchad, l'Europe ça va bien, c'est
positif. pour l'instant va bien. On
commence juste à se demander si nos
banques sont pas un petit peu exposées
elles aussi sur
le et sur des dettes fragiles liées à
l'industrie du pétrole. Donc les
dernières estimations qu'on a, c'est 180
milliards aux États-Unis. Alors là les
la fourchette, elle est très très vaste.
Il y en a qui disent qu'il y a 560
milliards de dettes liées aux juniors,
aux nouveaux acteurs du Shellil.
Certains prétendent que on serait plutôt
bien au-delà des des 1000
milliards. Bon, si c'est vraiment 1000
milliards, on est à peu près sur l'ordre
de grandeur des
subprime en
2007 et à l'époque le taux de
défaillance des sub prime ça commençait
vraiment à poser problèmes et à créer
vraiment des des des faillites en
cascade lorsque le taux de défaut a
dépassé les 7.
En Europe, on est certainement pas, à
une hypothèse de 7 % de taux de défaut
sur toute la dette liée à l'industrie
pétrolière.
Euh là par contre où je reste très
soucieux euh et pour revenir un petit
peu sur l'endettement chinois, c'est que
une dette qui croit de façon
exponentielle mais avec des perspectives
de croissance, mettons à l'horizon 2020,
est-ce qu'on pouvait encore espérer un
doublement du PIB de la Chine ? Si
l'endettement reste ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui 33000 milliards et qu'on a
une poursuite de la croissance, on peut
dire que la dette à terme pourrait être
résorbée par les fruits produits par
l'économie, par la capacité des
entreprises à faire face à leur à leurs
engagements. Et
aujourd'hui, les gens avec lesquels je
discute un petit peu de la Chine me
disent probablement on n'est pas très
au-delà des 4 % de croissance en Chine.
Et on a une dette qui elle par contre
continue de croître de façon
exponentielle. On est à 33000 milliards
aujourd'hui. Je pourrais qu'on
franchisse allègrement euh la barre des
36 milliards d'ici la fin de l'année. Le
Japon
présentait des bulles dans tous les
domaines, du
surinvestissement, sur capacité, mais
c'était quand même une économie non
régulée et une économie qui
s'inscrivait dans le le commerce mondial
au sens où l'entendre ceux qui parlent
d'un marché libre. En Chine, tout est
administré.
Euh les 33000 milliards de dettes dont
je vous parle, ce sont celles qui sont
connues. Mais il y a le Shadow Banking,
les Dark Pool. Alors ça, les Dark Pool
c'est tout à fait autre chose. Euh le le
shadow banking, c'est quoi ? C'est euh
des façons de contourner, je dirais pas
les restrictions que qu'impose la Banque
centrale de Chine parce que c'est tout
le contraire. Elle n'impose aucune
restriction, elle balance de l'argent à
tout va mais ça ne suffit pas encore
tant il y a d'entreprises qui sont en
difficulté. Donc le shadow le shadow
banking, c'est une façon de rajouter
encore du crédit, de l'argent euh dans
le système. Jérôme, Shadow Banking, Dark
Pool, régulation financière, les
pouvoirs publics tant européens que
américain que chinois, ils en sont où là
au niveau de la régulation ? Qu'est-ce
que ben je crois qu'il y a une grande
schizophrénie aujourd'hui dans le monde.
C'est-à-dire qu'à la fois, on dit qu'on
est un peu inquiet par certains éléments
shadow banking et autres, mais en même
temps chaque fois qu'on a un problème,
on on essaie de se sauver par la
dette. C'est-à-dire que on a affirmé en
2008 que on avait trop de dettes et
qu'on allait remettre les choses à plat.
Aujourd'hui, on a encore plus de dettes
qu'en 2008. Et pourquoi on l'a pas fait
alors ? Mais parce que personne n'en a
envie. Euh d'une certaine manière. Euh
si on remonte un cran plus loin, c'est
que euh ongorgé à deux espoirs. Un
espoir de croissance. Comme les gens se
parlent plus, arrivent plus à se mettre
d'accord, bah il y a une panique de se
dire "Bon sens, si demain il y a pas un
gros gâteau à se partager, on va se
mettre sur la gueule." et et donc nos
sociétés sont devenues des sociétés qui
savent plus fonctionner, ne savent plus
bâtir de de des accords s'il y a pas
s'il y a pas de croissance. Et d'un
autre côté, en plus, on est plus vous
avez des stocks de de
defs, plus vous avez des stocks
d'épargne et de gens qui attendent des
revenus. Donc, on a un bout de nous-même
qui dit bah oui, c'est quand même bien
tout ça, il faut qu'il y a il faut qu'il
y ait du rendement. Et donc aujourd'hui,
on est incapable de se passer de la
dette. Et donc on n' pas réussi
aujourd'hui, alors on a parlé de la
Chine mais il y a les autres pays euh en
développement. À la fin des fins, c'est
presque anecdotique à part pour
l'investisseur de savoir où est-ce que
ça va casser. Ce qu'on sait, c'est que
quand il y a trop de dettes qui
s'accumulent, à un moment donné ça
casse. Et quand ça casse, ça se
matérialise comment ? Ben, il y a un
actif qui perd de sa valeur brutalement
et et puis les gens qui étaient dessus
sont ont que leurs yeux pour pleurer.
Philippe, quand on a plus que ses yeux
pour pleurer euh et qu'il y a beaucoup
de milliards derrière et que ça commence
à faire pleurer les
États, si effectivement locale, on a un
scénario noir, je pense qu'il faut
investir dans l'industrie du mouchoir
parce que là va y avoir beaucoup d'eux
effectivement à à éponger.
Le problème de la
dette n'est pas n'est pas effrayant dans
un monde en croissance. Alors, nous
avons un monde où le rythme de la
croissance est en train est en train de
c'est on est en train de est en train de
chuter. Euh la dette génère euh génère
des intérêts et pour limiter la charge
que ça représente, on est en train de
basculer partout dans les taux négatifs.
La Banque centrale Suisse a été la
première à expérimenter ça au début des
années 80 et puis elle s'y est remis
récemment après avoir abandonner
brutalement le lien entre l'euro et le
franc- suisse. La banque centrale
sudoise est déjà bien avancée. Puis nous
avons ensuite la banque du Danemark.
Nous avons la Banque centrale européenne
qui s'y est émise. On a au moins six des
13 membres de la Fed qui se sont
exprimés depuis l'été dernier en faveur
d'une réflexion concernant le recours au
taux négatif. Et là-dessus, vous avez la
fête qui en décembre décide de relever
le loyer de l'argent. Alors pas de
beaucoup, c'est symbolique. Beaucoup
disent aujourd'hui que c'était le pire
moment pour le faire. Mais la Fed n'a
pris qu'une seule initiative l'année
dernière, la BCE, une initiative qui
était effectivement de lancer le QE et
euh d'adopter les taux de prise en
pension
négatif, elle va peut-être les rendre
encore plus négatif. Et la Banque
centrale du Japon qui a beaucoup promis
euh vient juste à l'instant euh de
passer également au taux négatif.
Pendant que les trois principales
grandes banques US, Eurozone, Japon
prenait une
initiative, la banque centrale chinoise,
combien a-t-elle pris d'initiative
monétaire en 2015 ? Bah, ça rimme 75. 75
initiatives monétaires alors
d'assouplissement, des règles
prudentielles, des injections. Alors,
tantôt en faveur des régions, tantôt en
faveur d'un secteur industriel. des
baisses de taux et elle dit qu'elle a
encore de la marge, ce qui est vrai
puisque je crois que les taux chinois
sont encore au-delà de 4 donc il y a
encore comme on dit de l'espace pour
baisser les taux mais quand une banque
centrale prend 75 initiatives au cours
de la même année, est-ce qu'on a pas
l'impression que là on est un petit peu
dans la frénésie ? Bon et que signifie
alors je vais vous dresser le
tableau. Euh on commence à avoir des
guerres un peu partout. On commence à
avoir des flux de migrants un peu
partout, de gens tant flux de migrants
économiques que flux de migrants dû à la
guerre.
Euh on assiste à une balcanisation de la
politique européenne. Euh si les marchés
financiers viennent un petit peu nous
mettre du
sel, c'est-à-dire que si on voit le
kiloderie prendre un peu d'inflation dû
à beaucoup d'injection de liquidité par
des banques centrales
américaines, à votre avis, la France est
elle est positionnée comment pour
pouvoir dire e les copains, faut
peut-être ralentir un peu et
réfléchir. Jérôme, tu peut-être
positionner de quel point de vue de bah
essayer d'appeler une réglementation du
système économique
mondial d'une façon plus raisonnée.
Est-ce que on a encore une voix est-ce
que la France est écoutée ? Mais de
toute façon, la France dans ce
domaine-là est
euh du côté de la non réglementation.
Euh la France euh est dans une logique
qui date de Colbert qui est de dire euh
les grandes banques françaises, c'est la
France et en fait l'intérêt national
s'identifie à l'intérêt de mes grands
champions nationaux. Et cette cette
idée-là va du Parti communiste jusqu'au
Front National. Il y a il y a une espèce
d'unanimité nationale sur ce sujet. Donc
aujourd'hui, la France a toujours freiné
des quatre feres sur tout ce qui pouvait
être réglementation financière. Euh donc
je ne pense pas que ça change
rapidement. Euh on a vu la Volteface
quand même de notre président de la
République euh sur ce sujet là qui est
quand même c'est mon C'est ça. Qu'est-ce
qu'il avait dit ? La finance c'est mon
l'enemi c'est la finance.
Et après, il a fait une loi sous
pression des
lobby BNP, Paribas et autres pour
éviter, préampter une réglementation
européenne qui aurait déjà été assez
tiédasse mais qui grâce à ça a été sié à
la à la cheville et qui a a conduit à
faire que le temps s'est éloigné et que
aujourd'hui il y a plus beaucoup de
pression. Alors, il faut pas
complètement injurier l'avenir. C'estàd
il peut y avoir il y a encore des
initiatives à Bruxelles. Mais mais par
rapport à la France, la France n' n'est
pas acteur sur ce dossier. La France est
frein sur ce dossier. Qui est-ce qu'il
faut aller voir dans le monde qui est
actif sur la réglementation financière ?
Ben le aujourd'hui le Parlement européen
discute de mesures qui reviennent sur
l'un des trois problèmes qu'on a à mon
avis. Aujourd'hui, on a trois problèmes.
Le premier, on en a déjà parlé, c'est
les animaux trop gros. c'est qu'il faut
qu'on arrive à dire à un moment donné
euh que ben plus c'est gros, plus alors
on commence à le faire un petit peu en
disant plus que c'est gros puisque ça
paye du capital. Le deuxième problème
c'est de sanctionner les dirigeants euh
parce qu'à un moment une organisation
dans une économie de marché elle
fonctionne quand même sur le principe du
chef et si le chef n'a jamais de
sanction l'organisation et jouit en fait
d'une d'une impunité. Et puis le
troisème élément, c'est la séparation
des activités de marché des autres
activités. Pas pour dire qu'elles sont
sales, qu'elles sont antinational ou je
sais pas quoi, mais pour dire que ce
sont des activités qui doivent être
cantonnées. D'accord. pour ne pas
justement le jour où elle dérape, c'est
normal quand on fait des paris que de
temps en temps on se gour qu'elle ne
vienne pas polluer l'ensemble du système
dont on a besoin, c'est-à-dire une
monnaie dans laquelle tout le monde a
confiance, un crédit dans lequel on a
tout le monde a confiance et d'arriver à
séparer cette finance qui est un service
public finalement de l'autre finance qui
est une activité qui en effet
s'apparaître s'apparente à des à des
paris quelquefois marche quelquefois
marche pas Les sanctions, euh vous
préconisez quoi ? Ben ça, les sanctions,
c'est en gros c'est les amendes et la
prison. On va pas on va pas réveiller le
euh la roue, le la pendaison. Euh donc
les pand les les les sanctions, elles
sont connues depuis la nuit des temps.
Le problème c'est est-ce que s'appliqu
Ben parce que la la les les lois sont
pas faites pour toucher les dirigeants.
En gros, on va on va toucher aux
porte-monnaaies beaucoup si on est aux
États-Unis, symboliquement si on est en
France, euh l'entreprise. Mais
l'entreprise, on le voit bien, chaque
fois qu'une banque est sanctionnée, le
lendemain, on a même dans l'heure même,
on a un communiqué où elle dit "Ah, même
pas mal."
euh parce queelle doit rassurer ses
actionnaires. Elle dit "Bon, vous m'avez
filé 3 milliards, c'est pas grave, je
vais quand même sortir un bon résultat
trimestriel." Donc sanctionner
l'entreprise n'a aucune importance. En
revanche, on est tous des êtres humains
et et si on veut faire passer un
message, il faut dire il y a une énorme
bêtise faite dans cette entreprise. Il y
a eu donc un défaut de surveillance. La
surveillance, c'est quand même le
dirigeant. Mais le dirigeant où il va
être interdit de travailler dans la
banque pendant pendant 10 ans ou il va
être il va aller en prison et le jour où
on aura un ou deux dirigeants de banque
en prison, j'ai un peu travaillé en
entreprise, je sais comment ça marche.
Je garantis que brusquement va
verrouiller un certain nombre de choses
dans les banques. Philippe, les
sanctions, les dirigeants pas poursuivi.
Parce que c'est du fait aussi que les
banques détiennent des dettes de partis
politiques et que si les banques
n'étaient pas derrière les partis
politiques, les partis politiques ne
pourraient pas se
financer. Je je reviens déjà sur le
principe toig to fail, toig to jail.
C'est-à-dire que les les établissements
hyper systémiques euh
il y a aucune sanction qui peut
s'appliquer contre eux. D'abord parce
que elles sont euh étroitement
supervisées. D'ailleurs, la Banque
centrale européenne s'en vente. Le
comité de supervision qui a rendu son
rapport début janvier euh a bien, on va
dire, verrouillé, évalué, peser
sousper n'a rien détecté d'alarmant.
Bon, le fait que la Dutch Bank par
exemple est 52000 milliards d'encours
sur les dérivés, c'est-à-dire 3 fois et
demi le PIB de l'Allemagne, ça n'a pas
l'air de véritablement effrayer grand
monde. En Europe, il y a au moins quatre
banques dont l'encour sur les dérivés
est supérieur à 30000 milliards de de
dollars. Et aux États-Unis, on est à peu
près sur les mêmes dimensions que vous
preniez euh les Jeep Morcan Morgan
Stanley, euh City Group. Donc tous ces
gens-là, tout big to Jail, trop gros
pour aller en prison. Mais ils sont
aujourd'hui, si jamais on leur
reprochait quelque chose, ils dirait
"Mais nous sommes supervisés
aujourd'hui. On on est à l'écoute, on
travaille sous le contrôle de la banque
centrale ou sous le contrôle de la SEC."
Vous avez pas l'impression quand je vous
entends quand je vous entends parler
tous les deux. Bon, je vous connais, on
va pas se mentir, on se connaît
bien. Quand je vous entends, j'ai j'ai
l'impression
de de voir des gouvernements qui
fonctionnent avec des cannes ou avec des
aides d'assistance comme dans les
voitures. Alors, la voiture a été mal
conçue. On reprend, je sais pas,
rappelez-vous une voiture de chez un
constructeur français qui avait besoin
de toutes ses aides électroniques pour
pouvoir prendre un virage à 35
km/h. On voit on voit ces gouvernements
avec des cannes et si on commence à
enlever une
canne, le système n'est plus stable et
que les propriétaires des cannes,
c'est-à-dire les banques, font
clairement passer le message que faites
attention, vous nous enlevez nos cannes,
on va vous emmener tous au fond. Donc je
reprends l'expression to be c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai à partir du moment où en
gros on met ensemble dans le même bateau
les activités de marché et les activités
financières de base que le commun des
mortels appelle banque c'est-à-dire la
monnaie et le crédit ils ont raison
c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment donné si
s'il mettent les crosses en l'air comme
on disait l'armée au 19e et ben tout
s'arrête et c'est cette espèce de
chantage de base qui fait qu'à un moment
donné aucun gouver gouvernement ne peut
en effet dire allez crever allez je vous
prends au mot je vous laisse crever là
au bord de la route c'est pas possible
parce que sinon ils nous font crever il
nous emmèneent tous avec parce qu'on a
tous nos comptes dans ces banques là et
et on ne peut pas se permettre ça alors
comment on fait quand on est braqué par
quelqu'un qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
messieurs parce qu'il nous braque c'est
un braquage c'est le case du siècle oui
il nous braque d'une certaine manière
tout le monde est complice he les
gouvernements sont complices d'une
certaine Tout ça s'est organisé en 25
ans sous les yeux de de de chacun.
Enfin, c'est pas un secret, c'est pas
une mafia au sens traditionnel. Bon, un
système s'est bâti comme ça. Il est le
premier lobby en terme financier de dans
n'importe quelle économie développée en
France, en Europe, aux États-Unis. Il a
donc des leviers absolument
invraisemblables.
Tu connais le volume de de d'argent
investi en lobbing bancaire ? Non, je le
connais pas. Je le connais pas. Je je
sais que le le la FB doit avoir un
budget de 50 millions d'euros, mais euh
on peut aussi regarder le nombre d'énars
que chez BNP Paris-bas. Enfin, le
problème, il est pas uniquement cet
argent-là parce que les les les gens
vraiment très hauts dans un pays comme
la France, c'est pas avec de l'argent,
on l'achète, on l'achète avec des des
mouvements de personnes et des des
services rendus. et et en gros, c'est un
système particulièrement en France où on
est très efficace pour rendre des
services, embaucher des gens et faire
tourner les gens dans une dans dans un
petit monde. Donc à un moment donné, en
effet, il y a que les citoyens qui
pourront dire "Arrêtons ce système-là."
On a raté la fenêtre de 2008.
Je suis d'un naturel optimiste, mais
j'ai peur qu'il faille une nouvelle
crise pour qu'on ait une nouvelle
fenêtre et j'espère qu'on prendra les
choses de manière un peu plus
rigoureuse. Philippe, est-ce que tu
crois
? Est-ce que tu crois ? Je pense que
dans le domaine de la
finance, on ne prend des décisions que
lorsqu'on est arrivé dans le Platan et
en 2008, c'est même pas sûr qu'on ait
pris les bonnes décisions puisqu'on a
remis le même chauffeur dans une voiture
dont on a encore gonflé le turbo. Et moi
une question que je me pose, moi j'ai
commencé dans la finance en
85 à l'époque où Cresson disait "La
bourse je la ferme, les boursiers je les
enferme." Mais à l'époque on se
préoccupait beaucoup du politique, on se
préoccupait beaucoup du géopolitique, on
se préoccupait de de l'innovation, on se
préoccupait de oui de beaucoup de choses
qui qui intéressaient à l'époque les
historiens. Et depuis
878, petit à petit, le seul sujet de
conversation sur les marchés, c'est
qu'est-ce que va faire la banque
centrale. La banque centrale jusque dans
les jusqu'à événement de monsieur
Greenspan était un petit peu l'arbitre
sur le terrain. Donc elle était là pour
laisser se dérouler le beau jeu si j'ose
dire.
Et puis la banque centrale, on l'a vu
prendre de plus en plus de sifflet,
siffler des
penalty, siffler des coups francs et
puis petit à petit, le jeu est de plus
en plus haché et de plus en plus, on se
demande mais quelle décision va donc va
donc prendre l'arbitre et puis à un
moment l'arbitre siffle penalty sur
penalty et c'est quantitative easing sur
quantitative easing, injection monétaire
sur injection monétaire. Du coup, il n'y
a plus de match. Ouais. Ce n'est plus
qu'une séance de tir au but.
C'est-à-dire qu'on investit plus, on ne
se pose plus la question de savoir ce
qui se passe vraiment dans l'économie,
dans le monde. Est-ce que notre planète
peut supporter que la Chine, par
exemple, comme je l'évoqué tout à
l'heure, voit son PIB doublé encore
d'ici 2000, allez, mettons 2025, soyons
raisonnable. On se pose plus ce genre de
question. La question c'est qu'est-ce
que va nous déclarer par exemple la Fed
lors de sa prochaine réunion en mars ?
Est-ce qu'elle va reconnaître qu'elle
s'est trompée en montant les taux en
décembre ? Est-ce que la BCE va rendre
les taux encore plus négatifs ? En fait,
on a complètement oublié le le contexte.
On en est simplement à savoir combien
est-ce que l'arbitre sifflera de penalty
en 2016. Et donc, on a plus besoin de
joueurs, on a plus besoin que de gens
qui tirent les penalties et le gardien
de but à la limite, il peut s'accouder
au poteau et regarder et regarder les
les ballons rentrés. On en est un petit
peu là. C'est-à-dire que on a les
banques centrales qui mènent le jeu et
ces banques centrales ne sont évaluées
par personne. Si elles se trompent ou si
elles font des erreurs que je pourrais
qualifier de colossal, là ils sont
totalement indépendants, n'ont à
répondre devant aucun comité d'experts.
Il n'y a rien au-dessus de la banque
centrale. Euh comment on fait pour que
les gens se réapproprient ça ? C'est
prendre conscience que que la banque
centrale augmente ses taux tout le monde
s'en fout mais tout le monde s'en fout
sauf ceux qui travaillent dans la
finance on a tout le temp tout s'en fout
pas il y a un espèce de consensus en
gros il y a une règle économique qui
fait que quand les taux baissent les
actifs montent et la bourse monte donc
en gros comme il y a plutôt des gens qui
ont intérêt à ce que la bourse monte il
y a un espèce de consensus mour pour
dire c'est quand même sympa quand les
taux baissent donc c'est un problème de
cast non non non je crois qu'il y a un
problème de fonctionnement de l'économie
qui est qui est devenu relativement
pervers. Après, parce qu'il y a quand
même plusieurs problèmes dans tout ce
qu'on discute ici, je pense qu'il y a un
problème de cast
dans un certain nombre de décisions de
régulation qu'on narrive pas à prendre.
Après, il y a un fonctionnement du
système qui est devenu complètement
pervers qui fait que les banque
centrale, c'est vrai que c'est le
pouvoir ultime, mais si on se met à leur
place, on voit que finalement leur degré
de liberté est pratiquement nul. Donc,
on est dans un monde où ceux qui
incarnent le pouvoir
absolu le absolument nul. Pourquoi ?
parce que ça fait 8 ans qu' baissent les
taux qui mettent de plus en plus de
liquidité et que quand il y en a un qui
dit tiens allez je vais faire autre
chose. La banque centrale américaine à
la fin de l'année dernière elle le fait
après avoir hésité pendant des années et
et immédiatement après tout le monde se
dit peut-être qu'elle a fait une grosse
une grosse bêtise. Donc pour moi, ça
donne pas l'impression de quelqu'un de
puissant quand finalement le degré de
liberté, c'est de faire comme les
autres, c'est-à-dire de dire "Je baisse
les taux et quand ils sont à zéro, je
remets de la liquidité parce que je peux
plus baisser les taux plus bas." Donc en
gros, il y a plus de pilote dans
l'avion. C'est quand même ça la réalité.
Et il y a plus de pilotes dans l'avion
parce qu'à partir du moment où on a
laissé les marchés prendre le pouvoir,
la logique du marché c'est quand même de
dire c'est gentil de dire qu'est-ce qui
va se passer en mars mais la vraie
logique du marché c'est qu'est-ce qui va
se passer aujourd'hui. En gros, on est
effectivement dans dans le day de
trading hein. La réalité quotidien c'est
ça c'est des hedge fund et c'est des 80
% du volume qui passe au travers de la
spéculation sur les ETF. Alors ETF
recouvre tout, les actions, les
obligations, les monnaies. On en crée en
permanence de nouveaux des plus
originaux, bientôt un ETF, je crois sur
le lien entre le
real le ral salouien et et et le dollar.
On peut donc spéculer sur tout. Mais
c'est pour moi, c'est presque plus grave
que ça. C'est-à-dire que on peut le
faire. Après, on va dire "Oui, mais il y
a c'est vrai qu'il y en a qui le font à
la journée, mais il y en a qui le font à
6 mois." Donc c'est c'est vrai que tout
le monde ne spécule pas la journée sur
les marchés, mais ce qu'il y a dans la
logique des marchés, c'est qu'on a
toujours l'impression qu'on peut
retourner la position. C'est-à-dire que
je prends une position peut-être à 6
mois, mais au fond, c'est pas très grave
parce que si en cours de journée voire
demain, je m'aperçois que c'était autre
chose, je vais pouvoir retourner la
position. Et ça pour moi, il y a
vraiment deux catégories de
raisonnement. Il y a ceux qui pensent
que rien n'est trop grave parce qu'on
peut retourner la position et il y a
ceux qui savent la logique industrielle
qu'à un moment donné, si on a commencé
un sillon dans son champ comme ça, si on
voulait faire les sillons dans l'autre
sens, il y a un sacré boulot pour
reprendre pour reprendre. Est-ce que
c'est pas ce sacré boulot qui fait peur
à nos gouvernants nos gouvernants et
cette peur les met dans une catatonie
intellectuelle qui est le pouvoir de la
la non décision, après moi le déluge et
on verra bien. Bah déjà, ils sont
terrorisés intellectuellement parce que
aujourd'hui si vous voulez vous prenez
des intellectuels normaux ou des hommes
politiques normaux, ils vont avoir un
avis sur la frontière en Macédoine ou
des trucs comme ça, vous leur demandez
la finance, ils disent "Oh là, ça j'ose
pas en parler, j'y connais rien."
La finance a réussi. Oui, mais lui
Macron, il est il fait partie justement
d'experts. C'est quand même un banquier
euh Rotchield banquier Rotschield. Donc
à un moment donné, c'est pas de lui que
viendra la réorganisation de la finance.
Je peut-être lui faire un jur que de
dire ça, mais c'est quand même de lui.
Pour moi, en gros, la finance a réussi à
dire que seul les financiers peuvent
parler de la finance. Ouais, c'est
triste. Et et c'est comme si on disait
que seuls les spécialistes du nucléaire
peuvent parler de l'énergie nucléaire ou
seuls les spécialistes chimistes peuvent
parler, on parlait tout à l'heure des
des problèmes des polluants peuvent
parler des pesticides. À un moment donné
dans une démocratie, il faut accepter
que certains médiateurs, ça s'appelle
des politiques, ça s'appelle des
journalistes, ça s'appelle des ONG,
peuvent sans avoir fait 30 ans de marché
avoir un avis pour dire "Ce type de
mécanisme est pervers, ce type de
produit est pervers." Est-ce que tu
viens de me citer les journalistes ? On
a pu la presse économique mais elle a
beaucoup du mal à survivre entre nous.
Aujourd'hui, on prend la presse
économique, qu'est-ce qu'il a fait vivre
? C'est quand même largement les
banques. Si on regarde le nombre de
pages de pub qu'il y a dans un journal
euh que je ne citerai pas, voilà. Et
donc en laisse, ils ont pas vraiment les
moyens d'avoir un avis autonome sur la
finance. Non. Donc les journalist alors
les ONG Finance Watch Finance Watch
qu'est-ce qu'ils font Finance Watch ils
ont des moyens limité mais ils arrivent
quand même à pouvoir dire non on peut
avoir des avis un peu différents sur la
finance les politiques encourage à
regarder leur site. Donc on va regarder
Finance Watch. Philippe qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ? Alors Finance Watch ils essayent
un petit peu d'attirer l'attention.
Est-ce qu'il faut qu'on commence à
aiguiser nos fourches ? Alors, je suis
un peu un peu rassuré qu'effectivement
on est euh des associations, des ing
tank qui ont quand même la compétence de
comprendre un petit peu ce qui se passe.
Les S tanks comprendre ce qui se passe.
Oui, oui, il y en a. Bah, mis à part les
éconoclastes, les autres, c'est en
finance un peu aussi quand même. Ils ont
des euh pour faire un un pitch court,
actuellement, le système financier,
c'est extend and pretend. C'est-à-dire
que l'on on roule la dette, on la
refinance et on prétend qu'elle sera
remboursée, ce qui n'est évidemment pas
le cas parce que parce que on a atteint
largement et très largement dépassé les
limites physiques des possibilités de
créer de la richesse à hauteur des
dettes qui sont
créées. En ce qui
concerne la
dangerosité du système et qui a été très
très bien illustré, c'est on peut tout
on pense pouvoir toujours retourner sa
position. Mais en fait, il y a encore
plus pervers. C'est quoi ? Il y a
beaucoup plus pervers, c'est que à un
moment, on se dit mince, on commence à
se retrouver euh dans un contexte
d'illiquidité de nombreux actifs. Ce
sont les actifs obligataires le plus
souvent, il liquide. Même certains
emprunts d'État. demeure enfin
deviennent liquides. Euh la BCE qui dit
"Je peux augmenter de façon infinie ou
quasiment
euh l'usage de de tous mes instruments,
c'est-à-dire mettre des taux plus
négatifs ou augmenter la taille des
quantitativas." En fait, il devient
difficile de trouver des dettes
éligibles pour être racheté par la
banque centrale, tout simplement parce
que par exemple l'Allemagne ayant
maintenant peu de dettes et on est
maintenant à pratiquement 30 % euh
d'émissions obligataires dont euh le
taux est négatif, celle-là la la BCE ne
peut pas les racheter. Elle est obligé
de puiser dans un gisement qui se
rétrécit. Alors, on est allé chercher du
rendement sur le Yield, ce dont je
parlais tout à l'heure, à propos par
exemple des dettes des groupes
pétroliers ou des juniors pétrolières
aux États-Unis. Donc, on est allé
chercher du risque et aujourd'hui, on se
dit ce risque malheureusement je vais
peut-être pas pouvoir euh m' m'en
débarrasser ou le retourner. Alors,
qu'est-ce que l'on voit refleurir ? Les
subprime, les CDS, les assurances contre
le défaut de dette dont on sait qu'elles
vont elles vont probablement mal se
terminer. On va donner les CDS à Jérôme
parce que Jérôme les CDS c'est son
rayon.
Jérôme ? Non mais je partage ce qui a
été quand je disais tout à l'heure le le
problème c'est de croire qu'on peut
retourner c'est qu'en effet dans dans un
marché dans l'économie dans la vie dans
99 % des cas on peut retourner et puis
il y a 1 % des cas où on peut pas
retourner. Et donc ce qu'on a fabriqué
c'est des mondes où en gros tout le
monde gagne très bien sa vie 99 jours
sur 100 mais au prix d'avoir de faire
grandir sans cesse le coût potentiel du
100e jour le jour où tout se ferme.
Parce qu'en effet quand ça se ferme tous
ces scénarios parlait tout à l'heure des
des scénarios de crise sont des
scénarios qui sont bêtes comme chou.
C'est-à-dire qu'on dit vous avez un
bilinons que les les taux augmentent de
1 %. Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Ah oui,
vous y arrivez, vous y arrivez pas. Très
bien. Sauf que le vrai problème, c'est
pas celui-là. Le vrai problème, c'est de
dire brusquement plus personne, madame
la banque, ne vous fait crédit.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Et à ce
moment-là, on peut avoir tout le capital
qu'on veut. On meurt très très vite.
Comme l'effet de levier d'une banque
aujourd'hui, c'est deux gens un capital
pour 30 d'ou 90 pour certaines banques
c'est 2 ou 3 %. Non, quand même quand
même. Bah la Bundes Bank son effet de
levier c'est combien ? Ah non, mais la
les banques centrales, oui, mais elles
émettent la monnaie, donc à la fin c'est
elles qui font la liquidité, donc elles
n'ont pas de problème. Mais une une
banque vulgaire, on elles vont se
retrouver à 1 pour 30. Mais ça veut dire
que ça veut dire qu'elles tiennent très
peu de temps si tout s'arrête. Donc en
gros, tous ces systèmes soi-disant
prudentiels ne tiennent que si
l'économie tient. Si à un moment donné
les gens arrêtent de se faire crédit,
tout s'arrête. Donc bal 3, bal, c'est et
donc en effet quand on voit surgir des
nouveaux instruments, ça veut dire qu'à
un moment donné, il y a des gens qui
s'inquiètent, c'est et qu'on cherche des
couillons pour reprendre certains
risques plus ou moins bien packagé,
prime moins alléchante. Voilà. Et ça
peut continuer encore pendant un certain
temps, mais tôt ou tard c'est c'est les
les les courbes comme on dit lecursif
qui ont en gros qui ont pas la
gentillesse d'être des bonnes courbes de
gosse dans lesquelles les catastrophes
n'existent pas. courbes sur lesquelles
sont basés tous les modèles bancaires,
mais qui sont des courbes qui disent de
temps en temps, il y a des catastrophes.
Et ben, c'est qu'un jour la catastrophe
arrive. Et à ce moment-là, on découvre
que tout ce qu'on s'est créé comme effet
de levier partout vous expose à la
figurine. Quand la mer se retire, on
voit qui est-ce qui a un maillot de
bain, qui encore à l'heure actuelle a un
maillot de bain. Vous avez un pays à
nous conseiller au cas où que il y ait
un si on devait partir
d'Europe ou c'est qu' on sera tous
touché. À partir du moment où il y a des
millions de gens intelligents qui
cherchent tous la sortie, c'est comme le
bazar de la charité.
c'est qu'à un moment donné le jour où ça
se ferme, ça se ferme sur tout tout.
Voilà, il reste au bazar de la charité
restait une fenêtre de 60 cm sur 60 cm
pour échapper à l'incendie. Il y en a
pas beaucoup qui sont sortis. Donc à un
moment donné, pourquoi est-ce donc ça ve
dire plus de retraite, ça veut dire plus
de financement de d'entreprise ? En
général, il y a les États qui arrivent
et puis qui qui essaient de une époque
c'était la troupe, maintenant c'est les
banques centrales. Mais là, on y est
déjà et on peut toujours le refaire.
Qu'est-ce qui nous reste comme cartouche
? Juste une plus grosse cartouche qu'on
a fait comme en 2008. Alors ça va de
toute façon l'esprit humain c'est de
refaire ce qu'on a déjà fait. Non mais
la grosse cartouche savoir quelle
répercussion sur mon kilo de pain mon
croissant le matin ça va le faire
baisser mauvais compte à un moment donné
il pourra y avoir en effet des
prélèvements sur les comptes de chacun.
Un prélèvement obligatoire. Oui faut que
j'aille je crois qu'il y a de plus en
plus de gens qui s'y habituent. Moi, je
rencontrais des gens là qui disaient
combien on va nous prendre. Alors moi ce
qui m'a beaucoup inquiété, c'est que je
me suis intéressé
euh à la garantie des dépôts
bancaires. Puis avec une petite
addition, une petite soustraction, une
petite division, je me suis rendu compte
qu'il y avait que 70000 comptes qui
pouvaient être assurés. 70000 € par
compte ? Oui. Non mais ça fait que 70000
comptes en tout compteu des réserves du
fond du fond. Le fond le fond fait 2
milliards, c'est ça ? 2 milliard 5. 2
milliards 5. Donc 2 milliard 5, ça fait
combien de de comptes en banque ? Petit
calcul, ça fait pas beaucoup.
Donc qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Si on
indemnise à 100000 si on indemnise à
100000,
ça c'est voilà, on on 2500 comptes,
c'est tout. 2500 comptes. Mais oui, ça a
toujours été ça a toujours été vrai.
Donc le fond de garantie des dépôts
bancaires, c'est du vent. Mais ça veut
dire qu'à un moment donné l'activité
bancaire n'est pas capitalisée à hauteur
de ces risques. Ouais. Ouais. et que
donc euh il y a un droit de la
collectivité à dire. Euh alors il y a eu
des tas de débats au moment de la loi
bancaire, les gens disant "Non, ça n'est
pas l'argent des salles de marché qui
serrent au compte épargne." Mais à la
fin, dès lors qu'on a une seule
institution, c'est la même institution
qui signe tous ces papiers. Et donc
c'est vrai qu'il n'y a pas d'argent dans
cette réserve qui est une réserve
professionnelle qui maintenant est
devenue un système européen. Il y a bien
sûr pas assez d'argent pour une crise.
On peut se payer une toute petite
banque, je donnerai pas de nom
provinciale en France. encore quelques
petites banques, il y en a de moins en
moins la Banque de France leur fait la
peau. Mais il reste encore quelques
petites banques pour qui pourrai être
absorbé par ce système mais une des
grandes banques bien sûr ne peut pas
être protégée par ce système. Et donc
s'il y a une banque qui saute et ben
c'est forcément la collectivité qui
vient. Et donc nous et c'est pour ça que
nous on a notre mot à dire. Le le
raisonnement de base, il est il est pas
de dire on veut embêter les banquiers,
il est de dire vous êtes en train de
jouer avec notre crédit de contribuable.
Peut-être notre vie. Ça n'est que lui
qui vous permet de fonctionner. Vous ne
pouvez faire des opérations aussi
gigantesques que parce que derrière vous
avez l'ombre de la collectivité
nationale qui vous protège. Et donc
rendez au moins hommage à cette ombre en
écoutant ce qu'elle a à vous dire.
Philippe, l'ombre, on ne la consulte
pas. Non, pas beaucoup. Euh, elle n'a
aucun pouvoir de contrôle. D'ailleurs,
quand dans les années 80 90, on a
commencé à concevoir la Banque centrale
européenne, les
concepteurs ont d'abord opté pour le
principe de l'indépendance et une
indépendance qui va donc très très loin
puisque personne ne contrôle ni n'évalue
la pertinence, la dangerosité ou au
contraire peut-être qu'on pourrait leur
envoyer des des des tombeaux de lettres
de félicitation. euh pour avoir inondé
euh le système financier de liquidité
sortie de de l'air ambiant, on peut dire
hein. Voilà. Euh donc ces nombreux de
l'aide de remerciement, ce sont les
financiers euh qui pour l'instant les
les adresses et euh les doutes ou les on
va dire les les
questionnements de plus en plus anxieux
euh euh du contribuable et du
citoyen. rien ne remonte jusqu'à la BCE
et de toute façon si jamais ça remontait
ça n'aurait pas le pouvoir de lui faire
expliquer quel est son plan par exemple
en cas de crise voilà alors en cas de
crise bon on sait déjà ce qui va se
passer c'est on a un exemple c'est
Chypre on l'a v et en Italie aussi il y
a eu deux faillites ou deux ou trois
petites faillites de de de banques de
banques dans dans le sud de l'Italie et
au Portugal où effectivement ils ont
pris sur les comptes alors pas que pas
que il y avait des des déposants dont on
a dit "Écoutez, vous pouvez pas faire
mieux ou trouver un meilleur rendement
que d'investir dans les euh dans les
dettes, dans les créances émises par
votre banque. elle est solide, on est
avec vous et des gens ont investi bonne
partie de leur retraite, une bonne
partie de leur épargne dans des emprunts
qui rapporter effectivement plus que les
BTP italiens ou que on va dire le le le
cœur du rendement moyen des euh des des
emprunts supervisés par la par la BCE.
Donc ces gens-là ont absolument tout
perdu puisque là on a on a rincé les
créanciers. Malheureusement, ça n'a pas
suffi et il a fallu euh qu'on aille bah
prélever les autres créances parce qu'en
fait quand on dépose de l'argent dans
une banque euh particulier ou personne
morale, on a une créance sur la banque,
c'est tout. Euh votre argent ne vous
appartient plus. Euh alors qu'est-ce
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Et donc et donc
lorsque la banque a épongé tous les
créanciers seiors qu'elle pouvait, bah
après ça elle est elle éponge le reste
et dans les créances dans lequelles la
banque peut puiser, il y a les dépôts.
Les dépôts, votre argent, notre argent.
Donc mon argent, ça m'intéresse. Alors,
où est-ce que je peux mettre mon argent
pour éviter ce genre de phénomène
? Disons qu'il y a un trou dans un trou
dans le mur ou dans le sol. La caisse
dépô consignation.
La caisse des dépôts Jérôme ? Oui, mais
comment on la met ? Il faut elle gère
pratiquement pas de compte à ma
connaissance peut-être pour ses propres
salariés mais la Caisse d'épargne Oui.
En gros, si on a si on n'est pas trop
riche, on peut on peut espérer être
protégé par la garantie à 70000 €. Puis
avec son conjoint, il a aussi 70000 €.
on utilise plusieurs banques et donc on
peut se dire que certes le fond ne
suffira pas mais le contribuable viendra
à la rescousse et après ce sera l'impôt
qui épongera et pas forcément son
épargne à soi en raisonnement un peu
cynique. Alors, il y a il y a des
banques qui euh qui n'ont comme le rôle
que de gérer les dépôts qui qui n'ont
pas de qui n'ont pas la casquette euh
banque d'affaires euh qui ne pilotent
pas des dragster financiers euh avec des
accélérations de 0 à 400 km/h en 3
secondes 6. Euh c'est-à-dire le Glas, on
en est où là ? a des banques qui qui
elles sont pas du
tout
glas ou d'autres fran aujourd'huis que
c'est d'autres fran n'entre pas en ligne
de compte puisqu'elles ne font pas du
tout d'activité de marché elles gèrent
simplement les dépôts. Celles-là me
paraissent relativement sûres des
noms on va dire qu'il y a très peu de
banques en France maintenant qui ont des
banques de de de dépôts pur en Suisse.
de marché crédit mutuel ils sont pas de
mèche avec le CIC. Si mais ils ont peu
d'activités de marché, ils en ont mais
ils en ont peu. C'est pas des grandes
activités de marché quand même. Il y a
le porte-monnaie
nickel du dépôt, on va changer de sujet.
Évasion fiscale. La banque pâche, le
documentaire sur Canal Plus qui s'est
fait
censurer. Qu'est-ce qui se passe avec
l'évasion fiscale ? Jérôme, c'est quoi
l'évasion fiscale ? L'évasion fiscale,
il y a la fraude et puis il y a
l'optimisation fiscale.
Traditionnellement, on distingue les
deux. Euh aujourd'hui, j'ai l'impression
qu'on progresse un peu quand même dans
parce que l'optimisation, c'est pas la
fraude qui dit pas son nom.
Ben oui, mais enfin dans un état de
droit, on est obligé de bien distinguer
les deux. C'est-à-dire dans un cas la
responsabilité est plus d'une
responsabilité de police et de sanction
des malfaisants. Dans l'autre cas, c'est
le législateur qui doit à un moment
donné son ménage et faire que ce soit
pas aussi facile de tirer contre le camp
du des États puisque c'est encore ça la
réalité. Et et aujourd'hui donc on est
en quelques progrès et il faut bien dire
que c'est les États-Unis qui ont aidé à
mettre un peu d'ordre en disant "Demain,
les États au lieu de se tirer la bour
vont échanger des informations entre
eux." Alors, je sais que tu aimes pas
beaucoup la notion d'échange
d'information mais à un moment donné
s'il y a des règles collectives, on
détruit une collectivité. S'il y a pas
le sentiment collectif que tout le monde
applique la règle. Et donc je pense
qu'il est absolument impérieux d'arriver
à une solidarité minimale entre les
États pour se passer l'information. Mais
j'ai j'ai je suis d'accord avec toi que
les États-Unis ont beaucoup contribué
mais j'ai l'impression que ça ne marche
que dans un sens. C'est-à-dire que les
Américains, ils aiment bien que les
Suisses collaborent, ils aiment bien que
le Luxembourg collabore, ils aiment bien
que la France collabore. Mais quand on
demande aux États-Unis de collaborer
dans l'autre sens, oui, les États-Unis
sont pas un endroit où il est tellement
agréable d'aller mettre son argent.
Enfin, je connais peu de Français qui
cachent leur argent aux États-Unis.
Peut-être pas au courant des des usages,
mais fle de la de la mais c'est pour les
sociétés, c'est pas Oui, les assureurs,
les laboratoires notamment. Philippe,
l'évasion fiscale, les chambres de
compensation et tout ce bordel là,
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire dessus ? Il
fallait quand on a conçu l'euro, je
désolé de d'où nous ramener encore 25
ans en arrière, mais enfin on pouvait
pas imaginer créer une monnaie
soi-disant optimale dans un ensemble où
vous avez l'Irlande qui siphonne les
recettes fiscales de de ses partenaires
avec le Luxembourg qui propose des
agréments où vous convenez de façon
presque forfaitaire du montant de
l'impôt que vous avez versé. Alors ça ça
existe en en Afrique. Euh je l'ai vu en
Côte d'Ivoire notamment quand je vous
dis je l'ai vu je l'ai vu de mes yeux
vu. Euh donc on peut venir euh euh
négocier euh sur la base d'une
estimation euh ben euh on bénéficie d'un
rescrit euh fiscal. Alors vous avez le
système du double sandwich irlandais.
Al, je vais pas vous embêter avec le
circuit euh de euh l'anéantissement euh
de la facture fiscale, mais enfin euh
avec un triangle Irlande, Luxembourg,
euh Hollande pour les holdings, vous
arrivez facilement à euh abaisser votre
taux d'impôt qui est, je pense, autour
de 25 à 28 % en Europe. La France est
malheureusement un petit peu au-dessus.
Enfin, grosso modo 25 et 28 %, c'est un
petit peu la norme
européenne. En jouant bien sur ce
triangle magique, vous abaissez votre
taux d'imposition à environ 4 %. Alors
comme tout le monde le fait, pas
seulement les multinationales
américaines, les les plus célèbres, les
fameux GAFA qui ont tous recours bien
sûr à l'Irlande. Et vous voyez qu'en ce
moment aux États-Unis, la la grande
mode, c'est de racheter une boîte en
Irlande pour ensuite délocaliser son
siège social et donc sa base fiscale en
Irlande où c'est beaucoup plus
avantageux qu'aux États-Unis. Donc en
Europe euh tout le monde s'y est mis. Il
y a pas de raison que on se fasse
concurrencer par des gens qui ne payent
pas d'impôts, qui de ce fait sont plus
rentable, ont plus de moyens financiers,
plus de moyens d'investissement, plus de
moyens de de de jouer sur les tarifs et
faire du dumping. Donc tout le monde se
met à faire de l'optimisation fiscale en
ne faisant que des choses absolument
légales qui misent bout à bout arrivent
exactement au même effet que si
quelqu'un euh frauduleusement
dissimulait son argent au fisque.
Jérôme, tu es d'accord avec ça ? Tout
est légal mais au final le résultat est
le même qu'une fraude répressible.
Ouais. Oui. Mais à la fin, bon moi je
suis internationaliste et donc je pense
que le problème il est il est bête comme
chou. Il est qu'à partir du moment où on
a des acteurs qui peuvent jouer sur
plusieurs pays et que les puissances
publiques restent enfermées dans un
cadre national, elles sont obligées
d'être à la fois limitée et un peu
bêtes. C'est-à-dire limité, c'est je
peux rien faire de ce qui dépasse mon
territoire et un peu bête. J'ai
malheureusement à très court terme
intérêt, si je m'appelle Luxembourg et
que j'ai pas beaucoup de richesse
naturell à attirer par des J'entendais
ce matin à la radio qu'on se félicitait
parce qu'il y a de plus en plus de de
films étrangers qui se tournent en
France. La France a décidé il y a
quelques mois de faire un un cadeau
fiscal qui jusqu'ici est à 20 % à 30 % à
tous ceux qui tournent leur c'est un
crédit d'impôt donc c'est un chèque de
30 % des dépenses qu'on leur fait. Bon
et à se gargariser les journalistes on
est vraiment les meilleurs. Les
Allemands sont et les italiens ces
couillons sont encore restés à 20 %.
Tout le monde se se congratulait. Et
c'est ça que j'appelle être bête, c'est
qu' en gros tout le monde se dit ça
c'est ça c'est finau. Non c'est pas
finau parce qu'en effet les Allemands il
y a quelque part en Allemagne quelqu'un
qui dit "Ah c'est quand même scandaleux,
c'est fr long français et cetera et ils
vont descendre, ils vont monter à 30".
Bon comme c'est le cinéma, bon c'est
l'exception culturelle, tout le monde
s'en fiche sauf que le système marche en
effet pour l'ensemble des activités. Il
fallait mettre absolument un terme, un
phénomène, c'est que toutes les scènes
des films américains devant ce enfin qui
était censé se dérouler à Paris était
filmé à Prague parce que ça coûtait
beaucoup moins cher d'avoir des
techniciens à Prague, des figurants et
cetera. Euh donc on va peut-être réussir
effectivement à filmer le nouveau appar
sauvé. Voilà. Non non, c'est on en a
résolu beaucoup de nos problèmes. On va
changer un peu de sujet ou peut-être
pas.
Euh je vais vous demander votre
perception en tantomme sur des sujets.
Alors faudra que ce soit rapide ce qu'il
nous reste plus beaucoup de temps.
Jérôme, état d'urgence, ça te fait
penser à quoi ? C'est légitime, pas
légitime ? Faut que ça continue. L'état
d'urgence, c'est un piège à con comme on
dit. C'est comme beaucoup de mesures.
C'est-à-dire que c'est des mesures dans
lesquelles on rentre et on sait pas
comment sortir. Donc là, c'est ce qu'on
est en train c'est ce à quoi on est en
train d'assister.
Et donc je pense que l'état d'urgence a
été décrété pour une raison
symbolique là où on imaginait des
situations de guerre et de crise
beaucoup plus faciles à identifier et
que donc c'était une mauvaise solution
dont qu'on va traîner pendant un certain
temps. Philippe état
d'urgence patriote patriote acte à la
française. Alors effectivement bah comme
d'habitude quand il y a une énorme
émotion des mesures émotionnelles et on
arrive aussi à faire d'énormes bêtises
politiques. Il y a pas grand-chose qui
distingue aujourd'hui le patriote acte
américain des mesures qui ont été prises
en cascade depuis le 13 novembre. Bon la
la presse reste un petit peu plus libre
aux États-Unis. On peut incarcérer un
journaliste si on considère que il a mis
en en danger la sûreté euh de l'État.
Ouis. Euh aux États-Unis euh la promesse
de Barack Obama de lever le patriot,
cette promesse n'a pas été tenue.
Guantanamoamo non plus. Jérôme euh
d'échéance de de nationalité.
Là encore un symbole qui qui est qui est
qui est complètement qui a complètement
dérapé. C'est-à-dire, je pense qu'en
effet, je n'arrive pas à comprendre par
quel aveuglement on a pris une mesure
symbolique qui dit l'exact
inverse de ce qu'il faudrait dire.
C'est-à-dire qu'à un moment où on voit
qu'il y a en effet
une un risque qu'une partie de la
communauté nationale euh se sente euh
ostracisé et et puisse pour les plus
fragiles écouter des sirènes tout à fait
nausé à bonde et ben on prend une mesure
qui avait peut-être au départ une
logique mais qui arrive exactement à
renforcer ce sentiment d'ostracisation.
Donc pour moi c c'est une mesure
catastrophique. Philippe,
moi je suis un petit peu plus balancé
sur le sujet parce que on a bien compris
que ça visait tout de même les bin
nationaux et des gens qui sur notre sol
professines. J'insiste bien dessus.
Laïque et républicaine. Voilà. Donc
c'est ça c'est c'est affiché comme ça
mais ça règle absolument pas le
problème. Euh des gens ayant le même
profil qui qui qui
vomissent le l'Europe et ses ses valeurs
humanistes. Vous les retrouvez aussi
bien en Suède
qu'embourg dans la banlieue de
Bruxelles. Voilà. Bon, ça ne résout pas
le problème. C'est vrai qu'il y a un
moment, bon, c'est une réponse
symbolique, mais je pense pas qu' elle n
elle n'a pas d'efficacité. Ça veut
simplement dire qu'on commence à prendre
conscience quand même quelque part qu'il
y a des gens qui ont obtenu une
nationalité française et si on avait été
plus fait preuve de plus de
discernement, on ne leur aurait
peut-être pas offert. Cherome,
moi j'ai j'ai vraiment du mal à voir les
les éléments positifs parce que je crois
que les éléments positifs, c'est très
simple. Moi, je vous avez plus de
nationalité. Je vous emmène dans une
prison secrète dans le fin fond du cul
de la Pologne et je vais aller vous
faire du waterboarding pendant 3
semaines. Vous allez voir que on a même
pas les l'administration pour ça. On n
pas on n pas les moyens pour ça. Donc
c'est c'est du fantasme. On c'est pas ça
qui va passer. soait c'estàd que je vais
voir Black Water, je dis bon écoute mon
pote, tu vas aller me choper ces garsl,
tu vas me les ramener alors le fait
qu'il soit plus de nationalité française
facilitera le waterboarding. Ouais. Où
je pourrais lui mettre pour moi, il y a
une idée une idée de de de dire c'est
génial, on va trouver un truc pas gênant
qui va faire plaisir à la droite sans
embêter la gauche. Euh et puis et puis
ça a dérapé. Mais là là où je crois
qu'il y a il y a il y a un risque, c'est
que finalement on n'arrête pas de parler
des binationaux, un sujet dont on
parlait pas beaucoup. Après, on peut
dire c'est très bien qu'on parle des
binationaux. Moi, je dis non, c'est pas
c'est pervers d'arriver à à mettre le
projecteur de manière quand même
globalement négative sur les binationaux
parce que après on tombe sur les les les
en tant que statisticien la probabilité
Oui, il y a peut-être un peu plus de
probabilité d'avoir des terroristes chez
un binational que chez un français.
Comme il y a un peu plus de chance de
pas rembourser des prêts chez quelqu'un
qui a eu un cancer que chez quelqu'un
qui a pas eu de cancer. La collectivité
nationale, elle est en train d'interdire
qu'on interdise de près les cancéreux en
disant que les cancéreux guérit en
disant c'est très dangereux d'ostraciser
une catégorie même si statistiquement
monsieur l'assureur vous pourriez avoir
un peu raison quelque part. Ça n'a rien
à voir. Mais je dis c'est un peu la même
chose parce que on a observé qu'il y
avait pas mal de binationaux dans les
terroristes d'aller aujourd'hui ouvrir
un débat de dire les
bit les binationaux pourront être avoir
une punition que les autres ne risquent
pas. Alors on change encore de sujet. La
big data, la big data dans les marchés
financiers. La big data dans les
assurances.
Big data pour moi c'est un gigantesque
rideau de fumée, une manière de vendre
de de la puissance informatique. Je vois
j'ai travaillé dans des entreprises, je
travaille dans des entreprises. Je vois
comment la plupart des décideurs avec
trois chiffres n'arrivent pas à prendre
une décision, ne maîtrisent pas bien la
règle de 3 et sont incapables en fait
d'analyser des données simples. Le
problème c'est que le cerveau humain des
décideurs n'est pas meilleur aujourd'hui
qu'il y a 20 ans, mais les ordinateurs
sont 4000 fois plus puissants. Comment
est-ce que diable on peut arriver à
vendre, à continuer ? C'est quand même
un miracle un truc qui double tous les
mois les ans et demi. Comment est-ce
qu'on arrive encore à avoir des budgets
informatiques qui augmentent dans les
boîtes ? Le big data est un des une des
un des arguments pour dire aux gens mais
vous saviez pas la couleur des cravates
des gens qui viennent dans vos agences
mais maintenant vous le saurez. vous
pourrez prendre des décisions averties
grâce à ça. Et euh mon assureur qui a
accès au pipe de big data de ma
cigarette connectée euh et de la boîte
noire de ma
voiture, est-ce qu' va augmenter mes
tarifs ou les faire baisser parce que je
fume ou je respecte le code de la route
? Et ça c'est une question vraiment
collective en tant qu'assureur. On a eu
tous les débats sur les conducteurs.
Est-ce qu'on a le droit de faire des
tarifs différents pour les hommes et
pour les femmes ? Maintenant, c'est
interdit si j'ai bien compris. Donc en
gros, le fait de savoir quelque chose
sur le risque n'implique pas qu'on ait
le droit de le transmettre dans un dans
un tarif. Et je pense qu'on aura un
grand débat dans les années qui viennent
sur cette notion d'algorithme. On voit
monter l'idée de l'algorithme. Est-ce
que je sais comment marche la boîte
noire ou pas ? Dans l'ancien monde,
l'assureur disait "Voilà le tarif des
hommes, voilà le tarif des femmes.
Demain, est-ce qu'on aura des tarifs à
la tête de pipe ? Est-ce qu'on acceptera
des tarifs à la tête de pipe en disant
si c'est moins cher, toi tu as ce tarif
là et toi tu en as un autre ? Et à ce
moment-là, est-ce qu'on demandera à voir
dans les entrailles comment est-ce que
ça fonctionne ?
Philippe d'un point de vue technique
déjà
euh il y a tellement de data aujourd'hui
qu'il faut mettre au point effectivement
les les outils pour les
exploiter. Soyons optimistes peut-être
que certains se dotteront tel Google,
pourquoi pas Amazon qui est dans le
cloud et aujourd'hui qui multiplie ses
capacités informatiques. Peut-être
qu'ils auront les moyens de faire
quelque chose de tout ça. Mais en amont,
quelque chose qui me qui m'embête, c'est
le contrôle des datas
justement. Tout le
monde collecte des datas puisqu'on est
on est hyper
connecté. Et aujourd'hui, où arrivent
toutes les datas qui me concernent ?
J'ai payé par carte bleue, on sait à
quelle heure où, on sait quel billet
d'avion j'ai pris. Euh si tu as acheté
un bouquin un bouquet de fleurs pour ta
femme ou ta maîtresse. Quel si j'ai
voyagé en catégorie à faire ou si au
contraire j'essayie de trouver un billet
pas cher avec un départ à 4h du matin.
Euh on sait en arrivant si j'ai pris un
petit déjeuner parce qu'il en servait
pas dans l'avion. Enfin, on sait
absolument tout euh qui contrôle ça et
euh partant de là, vu ce qu'on arrive
aujourd'hui à connaître au travers de
toutes nos traces euh numériques, ça
veut dire qu'en fait
euh Big Brower, il s exactement ou
quasiment ce qui s'est dit chez mon
médecin parce que quand je suis ressorti
avec mon avec mon ordonnance, je suis
allé acheter des médicaments adoc où
j'ai fait un séjour à l'hôpital où j'ai
fait tel type d'examen, j'ai tout réglé
par carte bleue parce que on prend plus
on ne prend plus mon liquide. il ton
téléphone sur la table et que j'ai
discuté avec mon avocat alors pour des
raisons soit fiscal soit patrimoniale ou
avec mon notaire j'ai pris des
décisions, on les voit tout de suite
parce que j'ai j'ai versé des
honoraires. On voit ensuite à la banque
s'il y a eu des mouvements de capitaux.
Donc on peut à peu près comprendre ce
que j'ai fait. Est-ce que j'ai
euh est-ce que j'ai modifié mon mon
régime matrimonial ? Est-ce que je l'ai
fait parce que j'étais malade ?
Euh alors ensuite
malheureusement après ce que m'a dit mon
médecin, je suis allé voir mon psy parce
que ça c'est un petit peu dur à
encaisser. Donc on sait que je suis allé
voir AMS. Donc là on sait que mon cas
vraiment devient un petit peu est-ce que
ton patron va accepter de t'engager
alors que tu vas avoir un c'est ça la
question c'est qui contrôle les données
comment là actuellement on voit que
l'Europe essaie enfin de verrouiller les
données qui sont collectées par les par
les Google voilà le le safe Harbour et
qu'on ne puisse plus trans les
transférer de l'autre côté de de
l'Atlantique. Alors peut-être
qu'effectivement on essaie de
verrouiller, mais moi je suis sûr qu'on
un jour on va on va glisser une un
câble, une fibre et on arrivera à
contourner et à et à exfiltrer toutes
les données vers des centres de
traitement aux États-Unis ou pourquoi
pas en Chine ou ailleurs. Donc vous
voyez aujourd'hui la big data, c'est
d'abord qui peut légitimement
l'exploiter et est-ce qu'il y a un moyen
que cette big que les datas restent
privées comme les l'entretien avec le
médecin, avec l'avocat, avec le notaire,
avec le psi ? Allez, dernière question.
Deux dernières questions. Jérôme Edward
Snowdon, ça te fait penser à quoi ?
Bah, rien de très original. Moi, je je
j'approuve la possibilité de de dévoiler
des des secrets. Je pense que je parlais
tout à l'heure des institutions trop
grosses. Je pense que un des problèmes
collectifs que nous avons dans un monde
de 8 milliards d'habitants, c'est que de
de d'avoir des
contrepouvoirs aux organisations très
grosses. Donc, je salue les
contrepouvoirs pour ou contre l'asile en
France.
Ben, je trouverai assez crâne de lui
donner asile en France. Je Il paraît que
ça nous mettrait dans des relations
abominables avec les les États-Unis,
mais on parlait de symbole tout à
l'heure. Ce symbole là en voit un autre.
Je je suis ami des États-Unis et je
pense qu'on ressemble plus aux
États-Unis qu'à la Russie ou à un
certain nombre d'autres pays. La Russie
a beaucoup changé, hein. Oui, dans tous
les sens. Ou oui. Euh donc voilà, c'est
vrai que ce serait ça serait quelque
chose de paradoxal de de se réconcilier
avec la Russie, de se brouiller avec les
États-Unis. Je crois quand même encore à
à la démocratie américaine plus qu'à la
démocratie russe. Mais au-delà de ça,
euh au-delà de de de la des plaisirs
qu'auraient les États-Unis, je trouve
qu'en effet ce serait crâne.
Philippe, on peut craindre que si on
accueillait Snowon sur notre sur notre
sol, on verrait se multiplier les
amendes de type BNP. ça nous coûterait
cher. Euh maintenant, je fais aussi
partie des gens qui
sont amis du peuple américain. Je suis
pas je suis pas je ne suis par contre
pas certain d'approuver toujours des
mesures qui ont des connotations un peu
néoconservatrice et j'observe que quelle
que soit l'alternance politique aux
États-Unis, c'est plutôt la ligne
néoconservatrice qui perdure euh et qui
gérait même a tendance
à à peser de plus en plus non seulement
sur les chiquiers géopolitiques mais
également sur les chiquiers économiques.
parce que essayer de redéclencher une
guerre froide avec la Russie, ça me
paraît quand même assez singulier que je
que je sache bon c'est certainement pas
joli. La guerre c'est pas beau. Ce qui
se passe dans l'aide de l'est de
l'Ukraine c'est c'est certainement pas
terrible. Ce qui s'est passé au Maidan
est certainement pas joli non plus si on
analyse ça en détail et qu'on voit le
rôle des uns et des autres et d'Olivia
Neland.
Mais jusqu'à présent, on n' pas encore
vu de
terroristes extrémistes ukrainien
russophones venir se faire exploser dans
une salle de
concert. et a beaucoup de pays qui
aujourd'hui soutiennent un petit peu
quand
même les mouvements terroristes et et
ceuxl pour l'instant sont
totalement on va dire indemn de toute
mesure de
rétorsion mise en pointe par vous partez
vous parlez des directeurs d'Asie
psychiatrique du côté de l'Arabie
Saoudite ?
Non, pas que pas que. Pour les dernières
questions,
Jérôme, un conseil pour les jeunes
générations, c'est une bouteille à la
mer, c'est-à-dire que peut-être dans 50
ans, on retrouvera cette vidéo avec le
conseil que tu vas laisser aux jeunes
génération. Pour endurcir leur esprit
critique, tu leur conseilles quoi ?
de de lire 1984 par exemple Philippe la
ferme des animaux du même hauteur donc
la ferme des animaux 1984 messieurs
merci
[Musique]